llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
France 24 por ello le doy la bienvenida
a nuestra periodista más Romero salamar
Buenos días Buenos días Andrés bueno
empezamos en Reino Unido las autoridades
anunciaron que se ha aplicado un
innovador método de reproducción
asistida de qué se trata sí sabemos que
son menos de cinco bebés no sabemos la
cifra exacta que han nacido con material
genético de tres progenitores distintos
algo que es absolutamente insólito y que
lo hacen gracias a un tratamiento que se
llama tratamiento de donación
mitocondrial vamos a ir paso a paso poco
a poco porque esto se complica hoy vamos
a hacer una crónica que parece sacada de
ciencia ficción las mitocondrias son las
pequeñas centrales eléctricas de
nuestras células dentro de la célula
pero fuera del núcleo están estas
mitocondrias que lo que hacen es
el oxígeno producir energía sacar
dióxido de carbono en lo que se conoce
como respiración celular y nos permiten
mandar energía tener energía para vivir
para existir básicamente pero yo te
quería preguntar a Andrés tú sientes que
has heredado la energía de tu madre Yo
creo que en la medida de lo que uno lo
Sí yo creo que sí pues no estás
equivocado porque estas mitocondrias que
son lo que te dan la energía a ti a mí a
todas las personas las heredamos
únicamente por vía materna por las
personas que dan el óvulo digamos en el
momento de hacernos nacer y hacernos
crecer Qué sucede que hay personas que
sus mitocondrias tienen deficiencias no
funcionan bien no funcionan no provocan
bien no producen bien la energía y eso
puede generar varias enfermedades
musculares en el cerebro en el hígado en
el corazón y si tienen hijos es muy
probable que les hereden también estas
enfermedades por lo tanto este método lo
que intenta es evitar que una madre que
tenga las mitocondrias enfermas le
herede esta enfermedad a sus hijos a su
descendencia cómo funciona vamos Sí como
decíamos paso a paso primero lo que se
hace es agarrar el óvulo ya fertilizado
es decir que ahí ya contiene el material
genético de Los Dos progenitores De ahí
se le saca el núcleo que es donde
precisamente está el ADN este material
genético luego se coge un óvulo sano de
una persona importante que tenga las
mitocondrias sanas y se le elimina su
material genético se le saca el núcleo y
en su lugar se le pone el núcleo
fertilizado del óvulo fertilizado de los
dos progenitores es decir que queda como
una especie de casa sana para el
material genético de las dos personas
que quieren concebir el hijo Eso hace
que la mayoría del ADN del descendiente
sea el 99% sea de los dos padres o de
los dos progenitores pero que igual se
cuele un 1% del donante o de la donante
de este óvulo que pues permite que el
hijo herede unas mitocondrias sanas y no
enfermas mar pero este tratamiento tan
innovador es todavía solo experimental
sí claramente como como suena es muy
experimental el primer caso conocido fue
en Estados Unidos que se supo en 2016 y
estos de Reino Unido son los siguientes
que se conocen Aquí vemos un comunicado
de la autoridad de fertilidad de Reino
Unido que revisa caso a caso
personalmente todas las solicitudes solo
ha probado una treintena de estas y solo
se le permite a las familias que no
tienen ninguna otra opción para tener
una descendencia sana ellos mismos como
vemos reconocen de hecho que estamos en
el inicio de estos tratamientos y que
todavía se tienen que revisar sus
desarrollos científicos y clínicos por
qué Por supuesto es una esperanza para
muchas familias pero no dejan de tener
dudas por ejemplo al ser experimental no
sabemos Cuáles pueden ser las
afectaciones a largo plazo se tiene que
monitorear qué pasa con estos niños y
niñas que nacen con Esta técnica y se
largo plazo y algún problema luego se
sabe que estas mitocondrias no se
consiguen sustituir al 100%, por lo
tanto existe una posibilidad aunque sea
muy pequeña de que los hijos hereden
todavía las enfermedades de la madre Y
por último siempre las dudas bioéticas
que nacen cuando existen este tipo de
modificaciones a mí particularmente me
nace la pregunta no si este tratamiento
es muy caro Y es de difícil acceso
podríamos abrir la puerta una distopía
en la que las familias que se lo pueden
permitir van eliminando no los restos de
estas enfermedades genéticas mientras
que las familias pobres se siguen
heredando pues mitocondrias no sanas y
por lo tanto con enfermedades a sus
hijos es algo que deberíamos estar
hablando desde ya a medida que la
ciencia avanza uno un procedimiento
parecido por ejemplo al de la maternidad
subrogada que también es bastante
costosa y no todo mundo puede pagarse
por supuesto mar cambiamos de tema para
hablar de una buena noticia en la lucha
contra el cáncer cuéntenos sí nos
pasamos la pandemia tú lo sabes hablando
de las vacunas de ARN mensajero y
diciendo también en este espacio de
salud que abrían la puerta nuevos
tratamientos por ejemplo contra el
cáncer y finalmente es cierto ha
sucedido con la empresa biontech que fue
quien desarrolló la vacuna con pfizer
pero que ha conseguido dar los primeros
pases en aplicar esta tecnología en
contra del cáncer de páncreas se trata
de un estudio que se ha publicado en la
revista nature En fase 1 es decir la
primera fase inicial solo con 16
pacientes al recibir una vacuna de ARN
mensajero diseñada ahora explicaremos
cómo 8 pacientes la mitad no tuvieron
ninguna respuesta no le sirvió el
tratamiento Pero hay ocho pacientes la
otra mitad que sí que se les o el
sistema inmune en contra del tumor del
cáncer de páncreas y que no tuvieron
recaídas en 18 meses un objetivo un
logro que no es nada despreciable en una
enfermedad que tiene una mortalidad del
88% y que se caracteriza precisamente
por eludir muy fácilmente el sistema
inmune por ser casi invisible al sistema
inmune del cuerpo y por lo tanto no
responder bien a muchas de las terapias
tradicionales que existen ahora cómo
funciona esta vacuna pues se basa en que
el ARN es una molécula que contiene
material genético que copia de nuestro
ADN pero que tiene la capacidad de salir
de la célula y de dar instrucciones
producir proteínas que nos permiten
respirar que nos permiten vivir es el
mismo funcionamiento con las vacunas del
covid-19 en este caso sin embargo lo que
hace este tratamiento es primero
extirpar El tumor en el páncreas de los
pacientes ese tumor secuenciarle
el material genético y de ahí
identificar una cosa que se llaman
neoantígenos que son las banderitas
digamos que tiene El tumor en su
exterior las células cancerígenas en su
exterior para que se identifique como
algo maligno lo que hacen Entonces es
diseñar vacunas específicamente paciente
a paciente con este ARN mensajero que
incluyan la receta las instrucciones
para producir estas banderitas estos
identificadores que permitirán entonces
que el cuerpo reconozca Cuáles son las
células cancerosas básicamente es como
decirle al cuerpo Mira tú no estás
viendo este cáncer no estás viendo este
tumor nosotros te vamos a enseñar dónde
tienes que mirar Cuáles son las células
que tienes que atacar en este sentido
también es muy importante destacar
también es un tratamiento muy inicial
que además previene no previene de
cáncer no es como una vacuna que te hace
pues evitar una enfermedad sino que
estimula tu sistema inmune para poder
combatir lo mejor y que como cada tumor
tiene su propio material genético se
desarrolla la vacuna personalizadamente
Cada persona tiene su vacuna de RN
mensajero Eso hace que sea muy difícil
por ahora imaginarse una aplicación a
gran escala por supuesto falta mucho
camino por recorrer saber cómo
combinarlo con otros tratamientos pero
es un primer paso pues definitivamente
esperanzador claro Muchas gracias han
sido buenas noticias hoy para la ciencia
buenas noticias hoy sí Bueno mar a
descansar nos vemos mañana entonces en
una nueva edición de salud aquí en
directo América Muchas gracias